[Music]
you want to know the secret to surviving
air travel you walk around on the rug
barefoot and make fists with your toes
how does that help you survive air
travel when you're not even on a plane
anymore or not even about to get on a
plane
kids take a trip back to the 80s when
handguns were allowed on planes smoking
was allowed in airports pregnant women
were advised to drink by their female
bosses 14 year old teenagers were
allowed to work as limo drivers and gas
was 74 cents a gallon wait what does
that mean does it mean the babies so
close to being do it might as well be
old enough to ten bar like 21 or doesn't
mean that this pregnant lady drank so
much during the last nine months that
the baby is already an alcoholic party
they're the only ones left in the
building well then why did you make him
type all that in the computer if he knew
where he was headed obvious cocaine
addict is obvious we Ellis has a private
bathroom yet he decides to do coke in
Holly's office John McClane will now
provide 50% of the movies dialogue with
himself this asshole needs a flashbang
to take out one security guard this is
the 1980s version of control-alt-delete
bad guys have no time for stairs bad guy
totally disregards the Pacific Bell and
buoys only side and yet another
stressful air adventure is magically
vanquished seriously Carl could have
this whole thing up by doing this what
would have happened if his brother
didn't get his job done in time everyone
ignores Hans and his gun toting crew
when they arrive even the ones right
next to the elevator how does he know
all about the cocky but not know what he
looks like and if he knows what he looks
like why does he bother asking which one
is Takagi this is the longest one floor
up elevator ride in the history of film
if the missiles get fired from like the
fourth floor then why did the bad guys
waste time in the beginning lugging them
all the way up to the 35th floor was it
just so John could see them and know
these guys are serious villains
I'm interested in the 640 million
dollars in negotiable bearer bonds whole
leaf Nakatomi has 640 million in bearer
bonds
after the Fiscal Responsibility Act was
passed in 1982 after this revelation I'm
not sure John McClane is killing the
right people in this movie
I mean sure Hans Gruber and his crew or
a bunch of murderous thieves but what
kind of does Nakano me involved with he
has cell phone coverage in an
underground parking garage in the 1980s
[Music]
what was John expecting what happened
here sure there are rules for policemen
his good old Tony says but the bad guy
refuses to drop his weapon can't you
just shoot his ass sure John it's you
against a bunch of well-funded heavily
armed bad guys rub it in that should
make your job easier
hey John now you don't have a machine
gun oh ho ho John shirt is most
definitely still pretty white while he's
in the air ducts but in the very next
scene the shirt is either change color
or we skipped over some kind of mud
wrestling base delete it see that's
racist or something
discount Huey Lewis well the first big
clue al Notre Dame and USC playing on
Christmas Eve in the 80s I realize movie
terrorists are dummies but this is
literally the least effective way to go
about hitting your target with bullets
can you actually interrupt someone else
on a two-way radio hans is probably
right about all those pop culture heroes
except Rambo John McClane and Rambo had
a falling-out over money in the world of
local news eat it it's the worst insult
imaginable Theo is not performing a task
that requires him to stop what he's
doing in order to talk Holly makes an
obvious look over to her family pictures
Hans sees the one that's facedown and
somehow it doesn't feel the need to look
at it going in man that's crazy that
could be over 30 hostages in there for
all we know instead of making a few
simple phone calls that would clear up
the situation the LAPD Convalescent
decides to go with the kick-ass first
and then figure out what's going on
method if our guy can hear the bad guys
on a regular world limousine CB why
aren't the cops smart enough to be
listening to the bad guys as well
thereby finding out in advance what's in
store for they're sneaky breach team
dama Dooley first
nestle crunch bar now a Mars bar how
will we ever settle this Warbeck Andy
companies if you keep switching sides
panning fire they can't see they were
shooting at the lights why couldn't they
hit them at first those things are huge
yeah how in the world do we get into
these glass doors if they're locked I
mean we clearly need a blowtorch right
this RV takes so long to drive to the
tower that the bad guys can reel a
rocket launcher in place even fumble
with it a bit assemble it and then fire
it before they get there is this how
Ellis negotiates multi-million dollar
deals how much nut kotomi not bankrupt
the material this suit is made from who
are you alright why would McClane bother
to give the play-by-play of his Twinkie
meal over the radio this isn't the kind
of coke that Ellis likes geez how much
did that bad guy pour into the glass
like a quarter of the can bad guys are
dicks two dicks did John give Hans a gun
with bullets in it of course he didn't
he's John McClane so now that he's got
confirmation that this is Hans Gruber
why doesn't he blow him away right now
or follow the bloody footprints out that
exit door and shoot McClane in the head
maybe the circuits that cannot be cut
are cut automatically in response to a
terrorist this whole plan relied on the
FBI cutting the power and they had no
backup plan in case they didn't and
everyone who signed on to do this job
with Hans was okay with that they got
the universal terrorists playbook and
they're running it step by step this is
a party line
not only would Powell not be allowed to
tell touching stories about shooting
children he also wouldn't be allowed to
tell McClane Jack about what the FBI are
doing also why is how disgusted with the
FBI for this move does he know the
terrorists are actually thieves and that
they need the power to be turned off to
open the safe when did Karl go from I'm
gonna fill this guy with a hail of
bullets as soon as possible because he
killed my brother too but first I need
to tell him how personal this is before
I kill him
these guys have were saying them
Uber's so did someone get in the
elevator go to the 30th floor and then
explode when they got there oh there is
not a ambulance in this truck it was
filled with a bunch of dudes remember so
this ambulance was supposedly gonna fit
13 terrorists in 640 million in bearer
bonds and they were one gonna smash
through the security gates after they
blew up the lead
remember Theo destroyed the computer
that controlled the security gates they
were either gonna have to smash through
them or wait for someone to cut through
them and they didn't think anyone would
notice the ambulance that somehow got
there before the gates were closed
also Department yippee-kay-yay yeah
let's review the movies most quotable
line and have a laugh about it during
this situation what how did this asshole
get out of those chains hanging by his
neck from a pretty decent height I would
say Carla's Houdini but Carla's clearly
better than Houdini
[Music]
neither one has got but national TV
Dwayne
[Music]
that's the last time bender that's the
last time you never make me look better
those kids do you hear me
I make $31,000 a year and I've got a
home and I'm not about to throw it away
on some punk like you forget it thank me
you want your chance to cooperate but
you thought it'd be more fun to insult
me well now it is my turn wiseass
there will be no foolish wand-waving or
silly incantations in this class as such
I don't expect many of you to appreciate
the subtle science and exact art the
dispersion making however for those
select few who possess the
predisposition I can teach you how to
bewitch the mind and ensnare the senses
have any idea what he had to go through
to get me that much I don't have time to
go into it but he went through a lot you
know how you can keep yourself occupied
this holiday season Hulu Plus all the
rest of your family is arguing two
months or hugging two months brothers
gotta or whatever else they do during
the holidays too much
you can find yourself a nice corner and
unwind with some of the best television
content around like one of my personal
favorites Shark Tank see I'm not usually
a home on Friday night when it airs
because I'm such a ladies man I am in
the wave of love so typically I use Hulu
Plus to get my fix if you like shark
tank or SNL or Jimmy Kimmel Live or
scandal you should head down to Hulu
Plus comm slash sins why because we have
a special two week trial offer just for
you fine people I'm kind of a big deal
so try it for free for a whole two weeks
now that'll get you through Christmas
New Year's and whatever the hell else
you're going to do the first week of
January so what are you waiting for go
now you fools go to Hulu Plus calm slash
sins today